So one of the fastest growing corona virus
hotspots is Florida.
Florida, of course, led by the completely
incompetent Smurf.
Republican Governor Ron DeSantis.
Now, DeSantis failed to even close beaches
in Florida until pretty recently.
He's been way behind on everything, even more
behind than Trump.
If you can imagine that.
And DeSantis, his continued failure has really
been putting Floridians, including the largely
elderly population in Florida, at really big
existential life and death risk.
And so finally yesterday, Ron DeSantis issued
a 30 day stay at home order that starts tomorrow,
Friday.
Florida has now reached about 8000 cases and
may likely be beyond that by the time you
listened to today's show.
And Florida is one of those places that Donald
Trump and others for a long time have continued
to say.
You know, Florida doesn't really have that
many cases.
They don't necessarily have to do that much.
The governor can decide what to do and what
we're hopefully by now realizing and many
of us knew it from the beginning because health
experts have been saying it is the folly of
not understanding how a virus spreads.
We call things going viral for a reason.
And now that has put Florida at nearly 8000
cases at what is still a relatively early
stage of the pandemic.
And remember, the effects of stay at home
orders often take two full weeks to be seen
that stay at home water starts tomorrow.
We could see a continued climb, a drastic
climb in Florida.
In both cases and eventually deaths until
the end of April or the second half of April.
I think better said this is what we mean by
going viral.
You initially don't have a lot of cases and
then you do consider a state with just 200
cases.
We hear, you know, from from Trump and sometimes
from Dr. Burke's.
You know, there are places with only 200 cases.
They don't necessarily need to do all the
same stuff as other places.
Imagine just 20 percent case.
Case growth.
Now, some places are seeing 30 or 35 percent
case case growth per day.
But imagine 200 cases growing 20 percent a
day very quickly in just 10 days.
You go from 200 cases to a thousand cases.
If at that point you say, hey, you know what?
Let's now put in a stay at home order.
You now are trying to mitigate the spread
of a thousand cases rather than 200.
And by two weeks, you could be, you know,
at 20000.
Who even knows this is how it spreads.
So DeSantis now finally issuing a stay at
home order starts tomorrow.
But, of course, it will take two weeks for
that to start really doing anything.
It'll be the second half of April.
And Florida very well could have instead of
eight thousand cases, they could have 20000.
They could have 30000 cases.
And this all happened without a stay at home
order, which is now being done in a panicked
way.
So I don't I mean, at this point, it's like
if you still don't have a stay at home order,
what are you waiting for?
But we should feel like we are overreacting
when some states early Washington to some
degree, California, to some degree, Massachusetts,
when these states said stay at home.
No.
You know, only takeout or delivery, it felt
to some like an overreaction.
You need an overreaction.
If you're playing policys take 10 to 14 days
to have an impact.
If you are reacting to the numbers you have,
you are already two weeks behind.
Florida has 22 million residents.
This is more people than many countries have.
Chile has fewer people than Florida.
The Netherlands has fewer people than Florida,
Cambodia.
Belgium.
Florida has a larger population than many,
many countries.
They've already got over 8000 cases, roughly
8000 cases.
It can get very ugly.
And Florida's demographics are not good in
the sense of who is at risk.
Florida has the fifth oldest median population
in the country.
Only Maine, Vermont, New Hampshire and West
Virginia have an older population than Florida.
We have to watch Florida.
It could get very ugly.
And Florida residents have not been well-served
by Republican Governor Ron DeSantis.
Horrible, horrible response.
And many Republican governors have done OK.
One of the best responses was Ohio Republican
Governor Mike DeWine.
A pretty good response was Massachusetts Republican
Governor Charlie Baker.
So we're going to continue following it.
And we are hoping that Florida will start
mitigating soon, because otherwise the numbers
are going to be absolutely tragic.